most of whales lives are hidden to us
you know we'll see whales at the surface
that's only a very small fraction of the
time that they're actually visible to
human eyes most of the time they're
underneath the water 10 50 100 meters
oftentimes deeper
we really had no idea until very very
recently the last couple decades what
they were doing down there and
technology has allowed us to really view
into the lives of these amazing animals
[Music]
whales are well known for their enormous
mouths able to swallow huge numbers of
tiny sea creatures in a single gulp but
when ecologist matthew savolka looked
through scientific papers he discovered
that no one knew exactly how much food
whales consumed
i thought it was so simple that it must
have been done before
i realized that this very basic question
uh in terms of how these animals live
was was unknown these details might not
seem that important
but whales are really important in
ecosystems and their functioning just
the size and the scale of their
consumption
has reverberating ecosystem impacts
that
as it turns out affects the structure
and the function of marine ecosystems
from the top to the bottom so what might
seem just as an initial sort of trivia
question
actually turns out to be quite important
for the ecology of the ocean and the
functioning of the planet the first step
in figuring out how much food the whales
were eating was to tag them over the
course of 10 years matthew and his
colleagues put 321 tags on whales from
seven different species
the tags tracked the whale's movement
recording in real time as they dove and
surfaced
this data revealed how often they were
gulping water and food like krillin
anchovies each time the whale came to
the surface but the tagging wasn't an
easy task the researchers spent hundreds
of days at sea
we work in small boats and uh that
enables us to get up right close to the
whale
and put a tag on and also we take other
samples so we'll take a little skin
sample as the well surfaces as well
if the whale does um have you know have
a fecal event as we like to call it
we'll collect feces as well for analysis
later so this is the glorious work that
we get to do collecting whale poop in
the ocean the feces told the researchers
what the whale was eating and the tags
told them how often but they needed more
data to tell them how much the wheel
consumed when it opened its enormous
mouth
we also needed to know the size of the
mouth because they have these enormous
expandable pouches that they fill with
water and prey
and to do that we're able to measure the
size of the animals using airborne
drones when they are at the surface
combining all this data gave a
surprising result the whales were eating
twice as much krill as previously
estimated
that means whales might be having an
even bigger impact on the ocean than
researchers had thought and that's
potentially concerning given that whales
face a number of deadly threats
including whaling accidental ship
strikes and climate change
losing whales could be devastating for
ocean ecosystems
we've seen declining ocean productivity
in areas
specifically where we remove the most
whales and before whaling there was
millions of these blue and fin whales
that were able to take krill for example
and turn it into fertilizer without
those whales you just do not get the
same fertilization
the whale's fecal fertilizer allows for
the growth of phytoplankton and
phytoplankton are essential for ocean
ecosystems absorbing carbon dioxide
oxygenating the water and feeding the
creatures higher up the food chain
all these animals that we know
and love
whether it's a sea otter or a killer
whale or a blue whale are all based on
this foundation of a healthy and
productive layer of phytoplankton that's
what the whales are able to do they're
able to bolster those populations in
those communities of plankton
so this is why we think that
underestimation of krill consumption
actually plays a large role in not just
ecosystem function but planetary
function this new insight into whale's
enormous appetites could inform
conservation efforts in particular
understanding what happens to the rest
of the ecosystem when whale populations
fall
when you actually realize that in fact
they were eating more krill than we
thought in the past and therefore
recycling even more iron than we thought
in the past then this has even bigger
implications for why we need a world
with whales